there are plenty of Harry Potter fan
theories out there but not all are
created equal
from theories that solve minor plot
holes in the books to others that miss
the mark in bizarre ways we've got some
of the best and some of the worst fan
theories about everyone's favorite
teenage witch Hermione Granger
if Hermione has one defining trait it's
her extraordinary academic excellence if
you've ever wondered why she excels so
much the answer might be her muggle
upbringing according to one fan theory
Hermione is such an excellent student
because she had morn on Hogwarts
schooling than most of her peers and
unlike Harry her family was supported my
parents dentists Hermione would have
attended muggle school until she was
accepted into Hogwarts at age 12
learning about scientific theory and
other non magical matters might have
contributed to a love of learning and
helped her considerably along the way on
the other hand maybe she just cares more
than the other students I'm gauge bat
before either of you come up with
another clever idea to get us killed or
worse expelled it's pretty common for
fan theories to take something seemingly
wholesome and twist it into something
dark and gritty
although the Harry Potter books get
pretty grim themselves in the last few
installments with numerous beloved
characters biting the magical bullet
according to one fan theorist though it
was actually even worse than it seemed
this idea supposes that Hermione spent
so much time with Harry and Ron on their
vacations because she was homeless
Hermione allegedly saw the writing on
the wall that Voldemort was coming back
so she erased her parents minds in
advance and couch surfed for her last
three years of school some of the best
fan theories are the ones that fill in
small plot holes when it comes to Harry
Potter there's arguably no other plot
development that's caused more headaches
than the time Turner the Hermione uses
in Prisoner of Azkaban why the Ministry
of Magic would let a student harness
time-travel just to take more classes is
a baffling mystery one fan theory offers
a convincing explanation
Hermione stole the Time Turner from the
Department of mysteries possibly what
Dumbledore's help you know the laws Miss
Granger
it must not be seen fans love imagining
that different characters are actually
the same character in different stages
of their life it happened with Walter
White and Breaking Bad and
all from malcolm in the middle and it's
happened with dozens of other characters
and actors usually though there's some
common element that makes the fan theory
at least vaguely plausible there's not
much plausibility in the fan theory that
imagines that Matilda from the classic
Roald Dahl story of the same name is a
young Hermione the theory seems to be
based entirely on the fact that both
characters are young girls with
supernatural abilities and brunette hair
there's really not much else to it which
makes it a pretty weak fan theory if you
disagree well listen you a little
wiseacre
I'm smart you're dumb I'm big you're
little I'm right you're wrong and
there's nothing you could do about it in
one popular fan theory Hermione's cat
Brook shanks was actually the Potter's
cat before Voldemort's attack there are
enough clues in the text to make the
theory work and it reassures cat lovers
that the Potters old cat didn't just
wander into the woods to die
most pertinently it explains why
Crookshanks hated Ron's rat Scabbers
it's because Cruikshank says the Potters
former cat would have recognized Peter
Pettigrew sent the Harry Potter novels
aren't exactly subtle about the
real-world parallels suggested by muggle
discrimination at Hogwarts Draco
Malfoy's obsession with pure blooded
witches and wizards unquestionably sets
him up as a villain it's also no
coincidence that Hermione as the series
most central muggle-born which is the
smartest character in the books it's
meant to highlight the inherit
contradictions of racism and other kinds
of discrimination all of which is ruined
by a fan theory that imagines that
Hermione isn't actually a muggle-born
witch at all supposedly her family is
descended from a long line of witches
and wizards but her parents are just
squibs someone born to magical parents
without any magical powers of their own
sure the theory explains why her Maia
shares the last name with a famous
wizard but it also tears a hole in
Hermione's character and a fundamental
message of the books themselves you see
Weasley unlike some my father can afford
the best at least no one on the
Gryffindor team had to buy their way in
they got it on pure talent fans lost
their minds with excitement when a stage
plays sequel to the original books Harry
Potter and the cursed child was
originally announced unfortunately some
Harry Potter readers were upset when no
Madhu mesmo knee a black actress was
cast to portray the older
for the stage this led a number of fans
to point out that the book never
actually clarifies that Hermione isn't
black
although the movies cast Emma Watson in
the role the books never explicitly
specify Hermione's ranks in fact JK
Rowling herself voiced approval of doe
mesmo knees casting blame George Lucas
for this one ever since Luke and Leia
were revealed to be twins in Return of
the Jedi a secret sibling revelation has
become a constant source of fan theories
for just about everything
the reasoning behind Hermione and Harry
being secret siblings largely boils down
to the fact that the two characters seem
to have a close relationship almost as
if they were friends
proponents of the theory also argue that
Lily and James could possibly have had a
secret child that they put up for
adoption
considering that Rowling herself has
admitted that maybe Harry and Hermione's
should have gotten together romantically
this fan Theory really doesn't hold up
to any scrutiny
[Music]